There are several measures you can adopt...
...to protect yourself and others from getting the new coronavirus.
Frequently clean your hands by using an alcohol-based hand rub product...
...like a gel, or wash your hands with soap and water.
When coughing and sneezing, cover your mouth and nose with flexed elbow, like this,...
...or use a tissue.
If you use a tissue, discard it immediately into a closed bin.
Avoid close contact with anyone that has fever and cough.
If you have fever, cough and difficulty breathing, seek medical care early,...
...and share information about any recent travels with your health care provider.
If you just have mild respiratory symptoms, and no specific travel history,...
...carefully follow the precautions I just explained...
...and make sure you stay home until recovery.
If you need more information on how to protect yourself from the new coronavirus,...
...check the WHO website at who.int.